good morning John I'm back and I'm
officially a dad which means that I can
make a video that I've wanted to make
for years but did not feel qualified
until this moment this is 41 bad jokes
in under four minutes now that I have a
son you might say that I have a a dad
bod but I'd rather call it a father
figure I don't know if you know this but
I can cut through wood just by looking
at it yeah I didn't believe it at first
either but I saw it with my own eyes you
know what the loneliest cheese is
provolone also did you hear about the
explosion the cheese factory I was
terrible the only thing left was debris
I just found out my friend was dating a
communist he really should have noticed
there were so many red flags to the man
who stole my thesaurus I have no words
for how angry I am no I've always hated
elevators which is why I've recently
started taking steps to avoid the hey
how long is dinner gonna be in love like
this this long you know I like to wear
these leather shoes when I'm sneaking
around at night cuz they are literally
made of hi I cannot wait for my son to
one day say to me dad I think I have
your sense of humor so that I could say
to him you give that back so why does
scuba divers fall backwards out of boats
as if they fell forward they'd still be
in the boat
alright up what what are you doing I'm
looking for Will Smith he always leaves
fresh prints hello how the earth rotates
it really makes my day hey how does
dinner smell through its nose I guess
feeling cranky baby there's an app for
that you know I don't like Russian dolls
they are so full of themselves dude what
is so funny I'm looking at mountain
ranges on Google Images they are
hilarious
so boiling water you will be missed and
I realize that oh right at Paul now
you're resisting arrest that's okay I
don't want them to accuse me of
kidnapping
Orion's belt huge waste of space get it
like waste waste of space with waste
yeah no I get it
it's not a great joke I'd give it three
stars oh you're done with your name this
is my baby
hey are you doing okay we're gonna take
you to mom sorry
what's Whitney Houston's favorites type
of coordination
buddy what are you doing what are you
doing I'm measuring your patience out
what do you get when you divide a poop
into three pieces Hertz you get how many
sides does a circle that is actually a
really interesting to the outside of the
inside man can I eat a quesadilla right
now a whole case why don't you just
start with one DIA and see how you feel
from there hey how's the temperature out
there it's pretty nice the only need
like a jean jacket oh so it's in the 80s
if Barack Obama say when he dropped his
shell at the beach no Michelle that's my
Barack Obama impersonation I've been
working on it so these two Pharaohs they
farted at the same time yeah they had a
Tutankhamun Oh son I'm glad I'm not your
math book it has got so many problems
what's the difference between roast beef
and pea soup anybody can roast beef how
do locomotives know where to go they go
through lots of training hey you know we
can get chicken stock in bulk yeah the
stock market hey what are you reading
this it's a mystery I mean doesn't it
say right on the cover one time I was at
this really skeezy bus stop and there
was a lobster with boobs yeah it was a
busty crustacean at a Krusty bus station
hey I'm deucer fish here yeah yeah we do
excellent Dave we'll have the steak oh
and man is a whole issue it's how I get
my food in a John it was real pat on the
back from you when Organic Valley
decided they were gonna sculpt me out of
butter it was a very big deal from you
was a turning point in my life I think
it made me a better man that actually is
the thing that happened organically I
like sculpted me out of butter because
people voted on Twitter enough and
finally don't my very first dad joke of
dad hood was we were headed out and he
needed a new diaper and so I was like
I'm gonna change him real quick and put
it on the changing table and I said now
what am I gonna change you into a
rhinoceros and I was like yes I'm a dad
I made an embarrassing joke and I got
peed on and I'm officially a dad and I
love it John I'll see you on Tuesday I
cannot believe how many jokes videos
I've made over the years you can watch
all of them I made a playlist boop boop
doop